einige stoffe gestorben und entschieden
unentschieden
da muss einfach mehr kommen weil ich
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zu einer runde bomberman auf der seite
bombe am endpunkt 10
01 1001 spiele der zusammen mit kraft
daher das ist auf jeden fall ein echt
lustige spiel ihr kennt das vielleicht
so von früher wenn ihr so in der schule
in der grundschule im computerraum
gezockt hab so was bei mir ich bin
übrigens gelb lukas roth und ich bin
infiziert ist oben links
hoffentlich klappt alles von der
lautstärke und ich würde sagen geht
drücken auf space bomben und dann kommen
wir manchmal power-ups raushauen kann
mir zum beispiel zwei bomben machen wir
kann die bauern schubsen wir sind
schneller wir können nicht die explosion
ist größer und es geht los ist das ziel
ist dass man den anderen in die luft
jagt und es wird sicher schwierig weil
man kann nur diese blauen dinger in die
luft jagen und man kommt sich halt immer
man kommt sich immer näher
irgendwann kommt halt immer näher
zueinander auf der karte und das macht
relativ und frank heimbau power up habe
alter dass mein status quo ab schon
jetzt habe ich alles einfach ich habe
hexen silverman tag des todes mit dem
heck des tores
du kannst schon schlittern alte ihr
natürlich bei den läuft kommen könnte
allein für das power up kaputt okay okay
wir machen drei runden machen oder fünf
oder so ich keine zwei bomben setzen
läuft bei mir ich kann 3 ich habe
trotzdem geworden
die tiefen der explosion
ich sagte ja ich könnte das was passiert
noch mal ich hab das erst jetzt gewonnen
wir machen wahrscheinlich fünf wohnen
würde ich sagen
denn ganz gut aus so viele ice teile ich
glaube jetzt diesmal gründig weil ich
spreche ich auch selber das ist diesmal
dass die runde über dem was schon
gewonnen bei mir lief haut einfach
risiko meine freunde schweren bombe
zusätzlich auch noch mal wenn wir die
ganze power ups einsammeln
das ist jenes angeles
ich kann noch gar nicht steht dann hab
ich's mir aufgefallen das ist knapp
jetzt mittlerweile heftigsten schaden
alter nein die schlucht des todes drin
gewesen
er bietet das abgenutzte spielen wenn
ihr mehr wollt geht einfach an daumen
hoch schreibt sich die kommentare macht
alles ich finds echt mit aller macht
alles was geht einfach bei uns auf das
nächste spiel kaufen das spiel soll ja
ach so okay es geht also ich finde echt
mega geil weil das ist ein spiel mit dem
ich wirklich meine kindheit so ein
bisschen drei weiße wir haben damals aus
unseren nokia handys haben wir yeti
sport und bomberman und alles möglich so
was halt gespielt ist heutzutage gucken
wie der youtube-videos hier
unverständlicher ist natürlich cool aber
ich finde ich fand die spiele damals
hatten einen anderen reiz weil
mittlerweile es ja so weit so flecker
bird doodle jump da fahren sie diese
erfolgreichen spielen diese alle mega
simple dinge die sind diesen alles ein
bisschen auf retro gemacht simpel und so
weil da sieht man wieder dass sie all
das ist nicht an der grafik liegt
zitiert die heftigste grafik aber keiner
spielsweise und am arsch immer so heil
wie viele aber jetzt kommt der
wissenschaft wurde
poldi skillshots die ganze zeit wo ich
bin ist es todes schnell ich selbst auch
nicht doch nicht nein mache ich mein
fahrrad kaputt offenes match von
einnahmen sich auch töten und die
treffen aufeinander
erst durch das das schussfeld geholt und
jetzt jetzt was und wer auf dem einzigen
punkt wo man nicht sterben könnte ja
jetzt auch wieder steht 2 1 für dich
noch der e mail adresse also warten wir
haben gesagt fünf spielen ja also 13 13
12 ausgehen für mich ist es drei hat für
mich würd's 32 ausgehen inhalt sicher
nicht
sicher nie ich habe die tour de france
wieder eingesammelt
ich habe schon drei bombenleger das back
to normal das spiel heute tech zone ließ
heraus ich geil da springe ich mich
selbst in die luft man es geht einfach
schon jetzt und in nrw es wird getauscht
was es geht um musik und wird so habe
ich jetzt alles erstmal bis ein
powerplay also damit so spannend also
nicht direkt auf den ordnung dass wir
versuchen erst das ganze eis kaputt zu
machen dann deathmatch alter wie gründe
ja ich war voll dafür gibt es schon
entspannter dann ist kann auch wieder
flittchen
ich habe mein eigenes pop-up
kaputtgemacht verkäufer schlecht in pvp
pinguin bath england mich im prüfzyklus
die wachleute gestorben ist einfach eine
gestorben und entschieden unentschieden
da muss einfach noch nie da muss ein
spiel
und jetzt die kleine verräter
das tut mir leid vergessen dass er
wasser instinkt als aber es war krass
einem unentschieden
das ist heftigste stelle die wieder das
für bombe setzen sind bestimmt
da ist das 2 1 1 oder was oder als
schneller beim legen kann dieses power
abwasser liegt das heißt dass mögliche
flächen können so die einzelnen banken
bedeutet dass man mehr können diese
kreist mit weit größere explosion und
diese flotten bedeuten dass man
schneller laufen können
ich verstehe nicht warum wir kurz gerade
in anderen farben waren sodass er
allererste mal also erstmal das ganze
eis kaputte bist ja com sowie geht eben
nicht vertrauen
ich war selber nicht ob ich selbst hab
ich nicht mit drin wahrscheinlich gerade
weil ich das wieder anders bearbeiten
aber leute ganz euch gefallen hat last
auf jeden fall eine bewertung da wir
wollen das jetzt auch nicht so lange in
die länge zieht das ist auf jeden fall
mega geil finde ich wie sage sonst wie
gesagt meine beschreibung gesehen heute
heute kann mir kein hero das war jetzt
ein kleiner ersatz ein kleines video
meine damen gehen
das stimmt